ja was ich da kritisiere ist dass sich
die Länder Europas und auch die EU
indirekt aus der Druckerpresse
finanziert haben wenn ich es mal so ganz
Platz sagen darf was passiert ist man
hat also
keine Steuern erhoben um sinnvolle
Staatsausgaben zu finanzieren sondern
man hat sich verschuldet hat also
Schuldpapiere verkauft an die Banken wo
man Geld zu kommen und die Banken haben
diese Papiere postwendend an ihre
jeweilige nationale Notenbank verkauft
die Bundesbank die Bank hat Italien und
so weiter das heißt letztlich haben die
Staaten sich auf diesem Wege in diesem
indirekten Wege mit der Druckerpresse
finanziert Druckerpresse muss man jetzt
ein bisschen allgemeiner verstehen das
Geld wird ja heute meistens nicht mehr
physisch gedruckt sondern ist
elektronisch aber von der Sache her ist
es das und da fühle ich mich schon so
ein bisschen erinnert an das was
Nikolaus Kopernikus der erste große
deutsche Ökonomen nicht nur der
Astronomen vor 5
1 Jahr im März war das nämlich gesagt
hat dass die Fürsten immer dazu neigten
ihren Hofstaat mit Gelddruck zu
finanzieren sie kriegten den Zehnten der
zehnte reichen nicht und dann haben Sie
einfach die das Silber Geld genommen was
in Umlauf war haben das eingeschmolzen
haben ein bisschen mehr Kupfer und
Nickel dazu gegeben und dann wieder
ausgegeben also hatten sie mehr Geld und
konnten also ihren Hofstaat und ihren
Lebensstandard finanzierenische Hausfrau
gab es noch nicht nee das fehlt im
Moment nicht auf aber auf die Dauer was
immer mehr Geld und und nicht mehr waren
und das würde zur Inflation und es
führte dann also auch vielfach zum
Untergang der Währung die meisten
Währung in der Geschichte sind
untergegangen weil die Fürsten sich
bedient haben auf diese Weise und man
kann man sagen lassen ist ja heute
anders heute haben wir jagen
demokratisch kontrolliert das System so
demokratisch ist die EZB gar nicht das
ist auch ein anderes Thema aber die EZB
und mit ihnen die Staaten benutzen also
Lösung diese geldschöpfungsmöglichkeit
um dadurch den Staat zu finanzieren und
jetzt haben wir eine große Inflation das
hat indirekt damit zu tun nicht
ursächlich aber es hat insofern zu tun
als eine Inflation entsteht wenn auf den
Märkten eine die Nachfrage größer ist
als das Angebot der Firmen und in der
Pandemie ist jetzt das Angebot gefallen
weil eben die verkehrten Probleme waren
china hat nicht geliefert die helfen
waren zu die Firmen die Fabriken waren
zu es wurde also nicht geliefert die
Einkommen wurden aber trotzdem
aufrechterhalten so als hätte man weiter
produziert und das Geld kam vom Staat
und der hat es sich letztlich von der
Notenbank geholt und da ist also die
eine Diskrepanz entstanden zwischen der
Produktionsmöglichkeit und den künstlich
geschaffenen Einkommen die Nachfrage
sind und das hat die Inflation erzeugt
also noch Platter gesagt die die
Pandemie war so eine Art Zündholz und
der Zunder der da entzündet wurde das
war die so hohe Nachfrage die die
Staaten durch die Verschuldung letztlich
geschaffen haben und damit sind wir dann
doch wieder bei Kopernikus und bei
seinem inflationsszenarium dass er vor
5001 Jahren sehr plastisch beschrieben
hat er war also wirklich ein
Allround-Genie nicht bekannt ist bei uns
im Bundestag besser geeignet als manche
andere könnte man sagen sie ausgenommen
aber
das ist so die die ewige Wahrheit des
Wirtschaftens mit Geld das diejenigen
die das Geld drucken können das einfach
sinnlich finden sich ein bisschen mehr
zu drucken und fällt ja gar nicht so
weiter auf und die Lasten verteilen sich
also bei einer Steuer schreibt gleich
jemand nein wir nicht die anderen ja es
ist riesen Tor aber wenn man das über
die Verschuldung macht ist es schon ein
bisschen diffuser und noch diffuser ist
es wenn man dann auch noch die
Druckerpresse mit einsetzt und diese
schulpapiere dann gleich an die
Notenbank verkauft dann bleibt das alles
in einem diffusen inflationären Nebel
und keiner weiß so richtig wer der
Verlierer ist und wer die Lasten tragt
aber trägt aber irgendwer trägt sie
natürlich denn der liebe Gott
nimmt ja nicht teil an diesem Prozess
und stellt steckt da keine Ressourcen in
unsere Volkswirtschaft rein die wir
aufessen könnten und den lebensstandort
machen können Ihre Ansicht nach wird der
Euro damit zerschrottwährung das
bedeutet das für unsere Wirtschaft und
wer trägt dann am Ende diese Schuld also
der Euro ist jetzt genau da wo die
Kritiker zu denen ich damals nicht
gehört muss ich sagen
was die Kritiker befürchtet haben das
ist kein stabiles Währungssystem sein
wird weil eben durch die
Gemeinschaftswährung eine Gemeinschaft
Haftung implizit für die Schulden
entsteht und diese Gemeinschaft Haftung
verhindert dass ein Land das über die
Stränge schlägt und sich zu stark
verschuldet dann besonders hohe Zinsen
zahlen muss das wäre der natürlichste
Prozess die Gläubiger die Käufer der
Papiere haben irgendwann Angst dass ihr
Geld nicht mehr wieder kriegen
naja also liegen ja auf der Hand hier
die im Mittelmeer Länder Griechenland
war ja im Euro praktisch im Konkurs 2012
also das sind ja klar definierte
es schreibt immer schreibt immer so dran
entlang nicht also normalerweise würden
die Märkte
solch ein Schuldenland bestrafen indem
sie höhere Zinsen verlangen war immer
höheren Schulden wird es immer
unwahrscheinlicher dass das jemals
zurückgezahlt wird und dann würden die
Anleger eine Kompensation in einem
höheren Zins verlangen nicht und das
würde die Länder wieder veranlassen
zurückhaltender zu sein mit der
Verschuldung aber wenn die EZB zur
Verfügung stehen und kauft die Papiere
ja dann ist ja keine Grenze dann können
die sich so viel Verschulden wie sie
wollen und ja jetzt können die Politiker
den äh so Schulden packte machen wieder
weigelpackt von 1996 der Stabilität und
Wachstumspakt der gesagt hat mehr als
3%, das Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist
verboten sie hat doch keinen Menschen
dieser Pakt ist 200 Mal verletzt worden
150 mal so über einen Daumen gepeilt
verbotener Weise eben es hätte Strafen
geben müssen keine einzige Straße auf
dem Niveau der Mittelmeerländer ja das
sind da kommen wir jetzt langsam hin
also es war ja die Frage ist ist der
Euro nach dem bundesbankprinzip
geschaffen oder nach dem italienischen
Prinzip also Bundesbank mag gleich mag
eine Mark steht immer für die selben
Zahl von Gütern stimmte damals auch
nicht ganz aber von der Idee her die man
damit kaufen kann oder Skala mobile das
heißt hier gehen die Preise hoch dann
gehen die Löhne hoch dann gehen wieder
die Preise hoch Skala mobile heißt heißt
Rolltreppe ja das war so das
italienische System die hat eine
permanente Inflation und haben durch die
Inflation ihre Staatsschulden relativ
zur Wirtschaftsleistung immer gedrückt
die bleiben natürlich
nominal gleich aber wenn Inflation ist
dann gehen ja alle Einkommen letztlich
hoch wenn auch mit Verzögerung einige
und relativ zu diesen Einkommen und auch
relativ relativ zum Steueraufkommen des
Staates
pulverisieren sich die Schulden und so
haben die Italiener immer gelebt das
Problem ist nur in dieser Inflation
funktioniert die Wirtschaft nicht mehr
richtig weil langfristige
kreditkontrakte nicht mehr funktionieren
wenn ich heute zum in Deutschland zur
Bank ging im deutschen System dann
konnte ich für 20 ja 30 Jahren fest
zinskontrakt kriegen ich wusste also was
die Zahlungskonditionen waren in Italien
gibt sowas nicht in Spanien gibt sowas
auch nicht warum nicht weil die
Inflation immer historisch so hoch war
der Gläubiger wusste nicht wie viel Geld
er real also im Kaufkraft gerechnet
zurückkriegt und der Schuldner wusste
nicht wie viel er wirklich zahlen muss
diese Inflation war Sand im Getriebe und
hat dazu geführt dass diese Länder eine
schlechte wirtschaftliche Performance
haben
jetzt die Kurve gekriegt würde ich mal
sagen
wegen dem Widerstand
sind wenn sie in drei Punkte mitgeben
das muss jetzt passieren sonst werden
wir da nicht umlenken ja wir müssen
letztlich das Eurosystem reformieren
Deutschland hat da eine Stimme genauso
wie Malta und wie andere
weichwährungsländer die nicht diese
Präferenzen für Stabilität haben wie wir
wir brauchen eine Stimmrecht nach der
Größe unserer Haftung und die Haftung
geht nach der landesgröße danach müssten
wir also ein Viertel ungefähr haben der
Stimmrechte dass wir dann Rassismus
jetzt kommt der andere dran da ist ist
man schnell psychologisch isoliert aber
wenn er Nagel dann noch einen Kollegen
hätte und noch einen und noch einen und
noch einen gemäß der landesgröße dann
könnten die sehr wohl die Stimmung im
EZB-Rat verändern und diese Bundesbank
Stabilitätskultur der Vergangenheit
übertragen man hat jetzt eine
historische Chance
eine solche Reform zu machen denn es
sollen ja sechs Balkanländer in die EU
aufgenommen werden
[Musik]
Bosnien-Herzegowina
Kosovo und so weiter an die EU sich das
leisten auch jetzt gerade in den
Kriegszeiten
Ukraine gesprochen
politischen und moralischen Bewertung
es spricht schon was dafür sozusagen
hier die rein zu schließen also ich bin
nicht grundsätzlich dagegen aber man
kann diese Länder die dann ja das Recht
haben den Euro einzuführen und das auch
tun kroatien hat jetzt gerade den Euro
gekriegt zum Jahres beginnt die kann man
nicht die gleichen Rechte geben in dem
System wie wieder Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die Bundesrepublik ist ein
Vielfaches an Volumen hat ein Vielfaches
an Volumen wie diese sechs Länder die
dabei treten und trotzdem wird sie dann
massiv dominiert werden im EZB-Rat also
das ist jetzt die historische Chance
sozusagen wir machen diese Art von
Erweiterung der EU nur wenn wir das
Regelsystem bei der Gelegenheit auch
ändern aber dann
kann man
das schaffen
jeder deutsche Minister Politiker hat
ein Amtseid geschworen und der Amtseid
lautet Schaden vom deutschen Volk zu
wenden und den Nutzen zu mehren und
dieser Amtseid wird nun seit Jahren
siehe die Flüchtlingspolitik und all
sowas gebrochen in diesem Fall ist es ja
geradezu Himmel schreiend wenn wir uns
in dem gleichen Prinzip jeder hat eine
Stimme aber wir bezahlen wie viel
bezahlen wir denn ein Viertel oder was
zum Beispiel durch die zinsenänderungen
die Marktwerte der Papiere die die EZB
früher gekauft hat runter gehen dann
sind ja voll lustig die tragen wir zum
aber ich bin wirklich der Meinung dann
muss man das ist eine
der Amtseid ist ein Erbe der unseligen
deutschen Geschichte dass wir ihn so
haben und dann muss man ihn abschaffen
also ich bin es langsam leid wenn äh
überall geschworen wird in den den
Schaden zu wenden und es wird
die halten andere die andere Hand schon
so dann ja nicht genau ja aber ich
wissen sie das sind ist alles
grundsätzliche Sachen sie können nicht
entweder wir nehmen das ernst und sagen
jetzt das hat mit Nationalismus und
sowas gar nicht so ich denke immer bei
allem auch bei dem Thema mit mit dem der
Einwanderung und Migration an den
schönen Satz von Peter Scholler Tour der
sagt wir können also gerne Kalkutta die
Hälfte von Kalkutta hier aufnehmen nur
dann bleibt Kalkutta Kalkutta und wir
werden Kalkutta und das ist genau auf
diesen ganzen Gebiet wie wir sind doch
langsam verrückt lassen wir uns mal bei
der beim Thema Wirtschaft vor allem
bleiben und bei dem was er sind gerade
geschildert hat man sollte annehmen die
Politik nimmt dieses Thema ernst schauen
wir mal rein
Geld aus der Staat ausgibt muss erstmal
erwirtschaftet werden das stimmt so
nicht denn die finanziellen Spielräume
in einem Staatshaushalt die ergeben sich
nicht nur aus den Steuereinnahmen
sondern auch aus der Höhe der Kredite
die man bei der Zentralbank aufnimmt
natürlich müssen diese Kredite auch
zurückgezahlt werden aber man kann
natürlich politisch festlegen zu welchen
Konditionen und in welchen Zeitraum man
sie zurückzahlt man kann in seine eigene
Währung gar nicht pleite gehen man kann
an seine eigene Währung gar nicht pleite
gehen deshalb macht das Sinn auch mal
über Kredite die Konjunktur in der
Währung zu stabilisieren
oh Gott das war Jamila Anna Schäfer
grünen Abgeordnete hat Soziologie
Philosophie studiert und sitzt der Sinn
seit 2021 im Bundestag hat sie damit gut
erklärt was sie nicht meinen ja was ich
nicht will ja das ist ja genau die
Mentalität die uns reingeritten hat in
diese inflationäre Welt das geht eben
nicht man kann der liebe Gott ist nicht
zur Verfügung und die Notenbank kann
nicht lieber Gott spielen sie kann zwar
Geld drucken aber sie kann keine echten
Güter machen die man aufessen kann das
kann sie nicht und wenn man das
berücksichtigt dann muss eben das Geld
so knapp sein wie die wirkliche Güter
Welt die das Geld darf man nicht darüber
hinaus aussehen und gar nicht mit diesen
Tricks das ist ja das ist genau das was
man was die Politik macht man druckt
sich das Geld für die Staatsfinanzierung
die damals offen gesessen die vom Himmel
fallen ja und genau den Glauben daran
aber es ist noch schlimmer wenn ich das
sagen darf wissen sie ist in der
Bundesrepublik der Sinn fürs Geld
einfach verloren gegangen und die
meisten Leute wirklich aus der Stadt
Geld hat und sind überglücklich wenn
seinen neuen euro-ticket Angeboten
bezahlen ohne darüber nachzudenken dass
das Geld mit dem das Ticket finanziert
wird Ihnen soeben abgenommen wurde aber
nur über die Inflation das ist ja das
was wir gerade hören ist ja über den
Gelddruck nein die ganzen Segen die
jetzt ausgeschüttet werden werden ja
davon finanziert dass die Leuten Steuern
berechnet werden also die Bürger
finanzieren selbst die Sozialleistungen
die der Stadt in einer Zuschauer wenn es
so wäre heute sind wir nicht in dieser
Welt wir sind in einer anderen Welt die
die Bürger zahlen ist nicht in Form von
Steuern sondern die Sparer zahlen ist
durch jeden
spaßvermögens ihre die
Lebensversicherung werden
das Problem der Zukunft sein sagen Sie
sondern heute man sagt über Schulden
sind eine Belastung zukünftiger
Generationen das ist nicht ganz falsch
aber heute in der inflationären Welt
tritt die lassen sofort auf bei denen
die nur Nominalwert gesichert der
Ansprüche haben das sind eben die ganz
kleinen Sparer bereichere Leute können
real sparen die können Aktien kaufen die
sind inflations geschützt aber
ärmere haben ihr Sparbuch oder ihre
Lebensversicherungsverträge und die sind
die gelackmeier die zahlen die Zeche es
gibt aber eine Art von Euphemismus ist
das Ganze befördert der Begriff
Sondervermögen ich weiß nicht also ich
bin kein Ökonom aber ich kann rechnen 2
+ 2 ist noch immer nicht fünf
Sondervermögen zum ersten Mal die
Geschichte der Nationalökonomie werden
Schulden als Vermögen klassifiziert zum
ersten Mal das macht also schon lange
wissen sie heitere Fröhlichkeit in der
Kanzler das Wort gebraucht hat
auch eine Infantilisierung des Vorgangs
Doppelpunkt und Sondervermögen stellen
ein Haus für zwei Millionen und das
Schulden sind der Bank und dann sagen
sie ihre Familie ich habe gerade ein
Sondervermögen genau
US arglistige Täuschung haben wir auch
bei der
Namensbildung bei
eu-vorgängen jetzt sind ja doch für
diese 750 Milliarden schuldentopf der EU
hat man den Begriff Eigenmittel der EU
verwendet deswegen in den Verträgen
ausdrücklich drin die EU darf sich nur
aus Eigenmitteln finanzieren einmalig ja
und zwar nicht aus Fremdmitteln heißt
das Fremdmittel sind Schulden die
Eigenmittel sind aber Schulden es sind
reine Schulden aufnimmt und wir haften
alle gesamtschuldnerisch dafür ja wir
haften also mindestens wenn wir anteilig
haften für mit unserem was weiß ich 20%
23,6 %. mit denen wir dann bei der EU
insgesamt da in der Kreide stehen und
wir haften vielleicht sogar noch mehr
wenn nämlich irgendwelche Länder pleite
gehen das ist ja nicht auszuschließen
Griechenland war pleite im Europa
einmal wurde es vom vom
Direktorium des ESM formell festgestellt
2015 im Sommer sie werden sich erinnern
dass andere Mal war es faktisch so im
Anfang des Jahres 2012 in so einem Land
pleite geht dann kann es ja nicht sich
beteiligen an der Finanzierung dieser
Lasten und dann tragen die anderen die
Last mehr notfalls alleine das heißt
nämlich gesamtschuldnerisch ja
der letzte alleine und wer ist der
letzte kann man sie aussehen
Wirtschaftskrise haben wir ja mit all
den Schwierigkeiten die damit verbunden
waren ja noch einigermaßen gut geregelt
finde ich jedenfalls wenn die Gefahren
das werden sie wissen besser wissen als
ich waren ja auch nicht gering wenn
nämlich mehrere Länder mal pleite gehen
würden deswegen bin ich immer ich habe
nicht ihren hohen Sachverstand aber ich
glaube die Inflation hat jetzt nicht nur
was mit dem Euro zu tun möglicherweise
auch mit gestiegenden Energiekosten und
mit dem Ukraine also das ist jetzt nur
an der Währung liegt würde ich jetzt
auch nicht so sehen nein nein nein haben
sie nicht gesagt aber sie haben
zumindest hätte man das so verstehen
können deswegen sagt mir daran
noch mal zu erwähnen die spannende Frage
ist wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt sehe
ich nicht am Krieg um das mal klar zu
machen
bei der Inflation der gewerblichen
Erzeuger waren noch nie so hoch in der
Geschichte
alles am Euro sondern es gibt aber es
gibt verschiedene Faktoren vielleicht
kann man sich darauf verständigen ja und
wenn man sich wenn ich jetzt davon redet
der Schaden vom deutschen Volker
abwenden müssen dann halte ich das dafür
für klug und sinnvoll diesen Ei zu
schwören
und die spannende Frage ist ja würde es
uns heute gehen wäre es besser wir
hätten die Europäische Union nicht der
Schweiz geht Union ist
ohne den Euro
besser funktioniert
im Nachhinein sowieso immer alles besser
gehört die auch was cool gesagt hat es
wird keine Schulden Union geben wir
haben das abgesichert
durchführungskriterien durch die
Maastricht pustekuchen also insbesondere
den Artikel der den b-out also die
Rettung der Schuldner der Gläubiger
eines kaputten Staates verbietet
125 €.v und 123 €v das keine
monetisierung der Staatsschulden
passieren darf das heißt die Notenbank
darf nicht die die Schuldpapiere kaufen
vielleicht den Unterschied machen Komma
vier Millionen 4400 Milliarden Euro sind
die Papiere gekauft
ja auch nicht das ist wie mit dem Rührei
sie können aus dem Rührei kann die Eier
nicht wieder herstellen wir sind jetzt
drin in dieser Tinte aber man muss dann
wenigstens versuchen das System langsam
zu verbessern so dass es funktioniert
ich meine wenn wir das jetzt einfach zu
pessimistisch ist das ist eine von mir
aus ihrer Analyse es gibt auch ein paar
Kollegen von ihnen die sehen das ja ein
bisschen anders aber
auch dafür gibt es möglicherweise
unterschiedliche Faktoren
sozusagen der europ jüdische Binnenmarkt
und das mal zu sagen ist ja eine ganz
grandiose Erfindung gewesen ist er weil
im übrigen gegen den Widerspruch der
gesamten linken Politik in Deutschland
weil die ja gegen jede Art von
Freihandel sind beginnt mit
transatlantischen Freihandelsabkommen da
sowas und endet dann oder begann
eigentlich mit dem europäischen
Binnenmarkt wir als Exportnation
Deutschland sind dermaßen abhängig vom
funktionierenden europäischen
Binnenmarkt im Übrigen hat es auch nicht
geschadet wenn wir dann eine
einheitliche Währung hatten
währungswechselverluste und alles was
damit zusammenhängt wie gesagt das
können sie besser beurteilen als ich
aber ich bin ich bin auch der Auffassung
dass man nicht alles auch immer im
Nachhinein ist noch einfacher zu
pessimistisch bewertet aber dafür
die Kritik aber das haben nicht die
Bohne zu tun mit der Kritik an der EU
die EU hat segensreich funktioniert als
Freihandelszone für Europa
wenn die EZB sich jetzt vorgenommen hat
die anleihebestände zu minimieren und
abzubauen dann müsste ihnen das doch
auch gefallen
bei dem allgemeinen nicht weil wir haben
ja die Opfer des Schuld sieht nur das
Positive ja nein aber die ähm aber nicht
nur immer vor wir haben ja eben diese
Wort der Kollegin da aus dem Bundestag
gehört das sind ja die Opfer des
deutschen Schulsystems die da jetzt
sitzen und die und unsere Wirtschaft
geht kaputt
verstehe sie nicht so negativ die Sonne
schlagen nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein ich erinnere mich nur
Wirtschaft geht es in wissen sie werden
es aus ihrem Wahlkreis wissen oder wenn
sie an der Basis sind es gibt heute
Familienunternehmer ich habe muss ich
ihnen das ist ja sehr pathetisch
selten so viele Männer weinen gesehen
wie ihr Lebenswerk innerhalb kürzester
Zeit kaputt geht sie traditionsreiche
Firmen werden liquidiert
Metzgerei im Bäckereien und so weiter
gibt's ja sowieso ein anderes
der Euro geht droht kaputt zu gehen und
wir sind in der Gefahr weil sie sagen
Exportnation wir haben ja bald gar
nichts mehr zu exportieren
nein ich meine in Anführungszeichen
kommen weil sie nicht mehr abwerten
können was sie eigentlich bräuchten um
ihre Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wieder
herzustellen also kompensiert man das
durch Geldtransfers und das Geld wird
dann auch noch aus der Druckerpresse
geholt wie retten sie jetzt die
Wirtschaft